leah has nine roly-polies let's write
that down
leah has nine Rolie polies in her
bughouse she has one more she has won
more than didn't GaN a is I think how I
would say that name how many Rolie
polies does Dingaan a have Dingaan II
have so that's what we need to figure
out so we need to figure out how many
Rolie polies does din gana have and so
this right over here is our question
mark now it's always good when you look
at a word problem like this you say okay
well didn't Ghani have more or less than
Leah
well it says she Leia has one more than
than Ghani so Leah is going to have more
and how much more one more
so did Ghani is going to have one less
than Leah if Lea has one more than than
Ghani then didn't Ghani has one less
than Leah so how do we write one less
well we could just subtract one so this
right over here this is one less one
less this is saying that Dingaan a has
one less than Leia so how much does
isn't got a half well he's going to have
eight Roly Polys eight Roly Polys now
another way you could have done it you
could have drawn Lee as Roly Polys 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and that would have been
them rolled up and you said okay that's
one more than Dingaan a so Dingaan a has
one less than this so one less than this
you just take away one of these and
you're left with you're left with 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 you're left with these right
over there let's do one more of these
whoops all right let's do one more so
they tell us the mass of a small box is
7 grams less than the large box the mass
of the small box is 6 grams so let's
write that they tell us the small box
small small box it has a mass of 6
and we need to figure out what is the
mass what is the mass of the large box
large large box this is what we need to
figure out so this is a question mark
now like we did in the last problem is a
large box can have a larger max or a
smaller mass and we should just look at
the names of the Box we should look at
what they tell us they tell us that the
mass of the small box is 7 grams less
than the large box so this the small box
is 7 grams less than the large box and
that's another way of saying that the
large box is 7 grams more than the small
box so another way to say 7 grams more
the small box is 6 grams plus 7 grams
that's 7 grams more that's going to
equal the mass of the large box so
what's the mass of the large box well 6
plus 7 is 13 6 plus 7 is 13 and we're
done